Tango me is Sarah's personal scheduling
page that lets her publish her
availability and invite others to
schedule meetings with her
Sarah created a unique tungle me URL for
her page she then customized her page
with the days and times she wanted shown
as available
she also added a photo personal message
and contact information
Sarah decides when and where she will
share her page
she has chosen to link it to her email
signature blog and Linkedin profile and
has even printed it on her business
cards
Sarah's Tangled me page makes it easy
for others to book meetings with her
here's how it works John is Sarah's
client he wants to meet with her so she
Skypes in the link to her page
he clicks it to see her available times
selects a few that work for him
and sends them in a meeting invitation
all without having to sign up
Sarah receives the email invitation
chooses a time and books it on her terms
it's automatically added to her calendar
and John receives a confirmation to add
to his calendar
Sarah chose to also sink her Tangled me
page with her existing e-calendar to
prevent double bookings
when meetings get booked or Sarah adds
new events to her calendar those slots
are no longer shown as available on her
page
it's so simple that Sarah shares her
tumble me page everywhere
she emails it to clients twitters it to
her followers text it to friends and
business associates
and has even installed the telephone me
Facebook app so that she and her tungle
friends on Facebook can easily schedule
meetings and see each other's
availability
it's a quick and easy way for Sarah to
let her network connect to her